㊟ヒカキンさんを軽蔑するものではございません。
テ↑テ↓テ↓テ↓テ↓テ↓テ↓テ↓テーン↓
PPAPぃ↑
デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）
デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）　ド↓デ↑デ→
（ペンパイナッポーアッポーペンピアノアレンジ）
デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）
デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑（チン）　ド↓デ↑デ→
（しばらくこれの繰り返し）
アイハッバッペーン
アイハヴァアッポ―
あぉぅぅっ!!(少々快感を感じた)
アッポォペーン
アイハッバッペーン
アイハヴパイナッポー
あぉぅぅっ!!(いままでにない快感を感じた)
パイナッポーペーン
アッポーペン
ピュｩｩｩ(効果音)
パイナッポーペーン
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛!!!(超絶快楽)
ペンパイナッポーアッポーペン
ペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペン
アッポーパイ
（ここからPERFECT HUMAN）
アッポーペン ×1
アッポーペン ×2
アッポーペン ×3
アッポーペン ×4
アッポーペン ×5
アッポーペン ×6
アッポーパイ(真顔)
パ～イナッポ～ ×1
パ～イナッポ～ ×2
パ～イナッポ～ ×3
パ～イナッポ～ ×4
パ～イナッポ～ ×5
パ～イナッポ～ ×6
ペン ペン 麺(不意打ちで笑わせるタイプ)
アッポーペン ×1
アッポーペン ×2
パイナッポーペン
パイナッペン
麺!! ×1
麺!! ×2
麺!! ×3
パイナッポー ×1
パイナッポー ×2
パイナッポー ×3
アッポーペン ×1
アッポーペン ×2
アッポーペン ×3
アッポー麺 ×1
アッポー麺 ×2
アッポーパイ ×1
アッポーパイ ×2
ア～ウ!!
ヒカキン
（ここからED終了までYoutubeテーマソング、だが本家とは一切歌詞が異なる）
(アッポーペン パイナッポーペン) ×1
(アッポーペン パイナッポーペン) ×2
アッポーペン
オ～ウ！！
ヒカキン
アッポーペーン
パイナポーぺーン
オ～ウ!!
ペンパイナッポーアッポーペン
アッポーぺーン
パイナポーペーン
オ～ウ!!
ペンパイナッポーアッポーペン
パイナポーぺーン
アッポーぺーン
ペンパイナッポーアッポーペン
オウ!!
ヒカキン
YEAH!!
♪~ED(YouTubeテーマソングver)~♪
（意訳：ＨＩＫＡＫＩＮさんごめんなさい）